3… 2… 1… Lets Go!
Tach zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Morgen kommt der neue Spider-Man-Film in die
Kinos, „Far from home“ heißt der, weil
er nicht wie üblich in New York spielt, sondern
hier bei uns in Europa.
Und da haben auch wir uns gedacht, wenn Peter
Parker schon mal um die Ecke ist, fahren auch wir los.
Nämlich zu Henry nach Jena!
Hi Jack!
Wir checken drei Skills von Spider-Man, gucken,
ob die im echten Leben funktionieren würden
oder ob da in Hollywood einfach nur „rumgesponnen“
wurde.
Skill 1: Spider-Man kann Wände hoch klettern.
So wie Spinnen halt auch an der Wand oder
an der Decke kleben.
Henry, wie müsste Peter Parker das anstellen?
Also Spinnen sind ziemlich cool und auch ziemlich
stark.
Die können nämlich bis zum 170-fachen ihres
eigenen Körpergewichts kopfüber an der Decke tragen.
Und das machen die dadurch, dass sie an ihren
kleinen Füßen ganz viele Haare haben.
Und auf diesen Haaren haben sie noch mehr,
noch kleinere Haare.
Die haben Haare auf Ihren Haaren?
Genau.
Und diese winzig kleinen Haare sind nur im
Nanometer Größenbereich, das heißt Millionstel von einem Millimeter.
Wenn Dinge so klein werden, dann spielen Atomare
Wechselwirkungen eine Rolle.
Atome bestehen ja aus einer Hülle, die ist
negativ geladen, und einem Kern der ist positiv geladen.
Ladungen verhalten sich so, Ladungen verhalten
sich so, dass sich gleiche Ladungen, also
positive und positive oder negative und negative
gegenseitig abstoßen und negative und positive sich gegenseitig anziehen.
Wenn man jetzt ein Atom in die Nähe eines
anderen bringt, dann kommt es ein bisschen
auf die Atmomsorte an, aber es kann eben passieren,
dass die Hülle des einen die Hülle des anderen
ein Stück zur Seite schiebt und dann ist
der positive Kern in der Nähe der negativen
Hülle des anderen und dann kommt es zu
einer Anziehung.
Und diese Anziehung nennt man „Van-der-Waals-Wechselwirkung“
oder „Van-der-Waals-Kräfte“.
Die sind relativ schwach aber dadurch, dass
es so viele Haare sind wird der Effekt entsprechend groß.
Das heißt, wenn diese Effekte sich potenzieren,
dann müssten wir rauskriegen wie viele Haare
Spider-Man bräuchte um sich halten zu können.
Henry kann man das ausrechnen?
Das Internet sagt, Peter Parker wiegt 76 kg
und rechnet man das auf Haare um, dann bräuchte
Peter Parker an Händen und Füßen 18 Milliarden
Haare um sein eigenes Körpergewicht zu halten.
Irre.
Unglaublich viel.
Das heißt, es würde funktionieren, Spider-Man
könnte Wände hochlaufen wenn er einfach
sehr sehr haarige Hände und Füße hätte.
Skill 2 sind die Spinnenfäden, die Spider-Man
so lässig aus dem Handgelenk schießt.
In „Far From Home“ spinnt er damit eine
Gruppe von Verbrechern ein und hängt die damit unter die Decke.
Es gibt auch aus dem Vorgängerteil, „Homecoming“,
noch eine andere Szene.
Eine ganz klassische Horror-Vorstellung.
Da sind nämlich Leute in einem Fahrstuhl
und dieser droht abzustürzen und Spider-Man
kommt, schießt seine Spinnfäden und hält
so diese Fahrstuhlkabine auf.
Würde das funktionieren? Ist das realistisch?
Wenn der mit seiner Fallgeschwindigkeit auf
dem Boden auftrifft, würde er innerhalb kürzester
Zeit von dieser Geschwindigkeit auf 0 abgebremst.
Je kürzer diese Zeit ist, desto größer
ist die Kraft die diesen Fahrstuhl abbremst
und natürlich auch die Kraft, die auf die
Insassen da drin wirkt.
Was ich mich bei dieser Szene frage ist, wenn
Spider-Man jetzt seinen Faden schießt, dann
bremst er diesen Fahrstuhl doch genauso abrupt
ab.
Kommt dann nicht derselbe Effekt zum tragen?
Nicht ganz, denn Spinnfäden verhalten sich
ein bisschen anders.
Wie man im Film sieht, ist der Faden elastisch.
Das heißt ein Teil der wirkenden Kraft wird
dazu genutzt, den Faden zu dehnen.
Spinnfäden sind wie so Perlen die auf einer
Kette aufgereiht sind und in diesen kleinen
Perlen oder Kammern sind Proteine aufgewickelt.
Wenn der Faden jetzt belastet wird, dann wickeln
sich diese Proteine ab und es funktioniert
im Prinzip wie bei der Dehnung von einer Feder.
Das sind viele kleine Federn die aneinander
gereiht sind, und die dehnen sich bei Belastung aus.
Wenn die Kraft jetzt wieder abnimmt, dann
zieht sich die Feder wieder zusammen, die
Proteine wickeln sich auf und alles ist wieder
fein.
Das heißt, es ist keine Hollywood-Spinnerei
sondern das ist tatsächlich so.
Und es würde funktionieren.
Genau – True Story.
Skill 3: Spider-Man kann an diesen
Spinnfäden durch Häuserschluchten schwingen.
Und das sieht ziemlich cool aus und wir wissen
jetzt auch, dass diese Fäden elastisch sind
aber können die diese Kraft auch aushalten?
Also würden die reißen oder nicht?
Da müssen wir uns zuerst überlegen, was
für eine Kraft in diesem Faden wirkt.
Wenn sich Spider-Man auf einer Kreisbahn bewegt,
eigentlich ist es keine richtige Kreisbahn
weil der Faden elastisch ist, das heißt,
es würde eher ein bisschen wie eine Eierform werden.
Aber damit wir einfacher rechnen können,
nehmen wir an, dass es eine Kreisbahn ist.
Die Kraft, die etwas auf einer Kreisbahn hält
und sozusagen den Bewegungszustand von Spider-Man
ändert nennt man Zentripetalkraft.
Und diese Zentripetalkraft muss jetzt die
Gewichtskraft von Spider-Man kompensieren
und zusätzlich dafür sorgen, dass er bei
einer bestimmten Geschwindigkeit auf dieser
Kreisbahn gehalten wird. Sie muss ihn im Prinzip nach oben ziehen.
Diese Kraft ist am Größten, wenn Spider-Man
genau unten durch diese Kreisbahn hindurch schwingt.
Und das können wir Euch an einem kleinen
Schauexperiment nochmal zeigen.
Wir haben hier einen Spider-Man auf ein Smartphone
geklebt und auf diesem Smartphone ist eine App – eine freie App von der Uni Aachen.
Diese misst jetzt gleiche die Beschleunigung
über die Sensoren im Telefon.
Henry, warum machen wir das?
Mit der Beschleunigung können wir die Kraft
berechnen, die auf Spider-Man wirkt wenn er
an diesem Faden rum schwingt.
Okay und darüber können wir nachher berechnen,
wie viel Kraft hier auf dem Faden wirkt und
wie viel der aushalten muss.
Dann lassen wir Spider-Man jetzt einfach mal
schwingen.
3… 2… 1… Lets Go!
Sehr gut.
Was können wir, anhand dieser Messwerte die
wir hier im Computer sehen, jetzt erkennen?
Was wir erkennen ist ein auf und ab der Beschleunigung
und genau dort, wo die Beschleunigung am größten
ist, wo sie diese Peaks hat, geht Spider-Man
genau in der Mitte durch.
Mit Hilfe dieser Beschleunigung können wir
die Kraft berechnen, die auf Spider-Man wirkt.
Sehr gut!
Dann schnappen wir uns jetzt den Messwert
und machen mal ne Rechnung an der Tafel.
So wir haben jetzt also einen Messwert rausgekriegt,
nämlich am tiefsten Punkt hier bei der Schwingung,
haben wir eine Beschleunigung von dem Handy
von 12,5 m/s² gehabt.
Wir haben die Länge vom Faden vorher gemessen,
da sind wir bei 5,2 m und darauf kriegen wir
eine Geschwindigkeit von ungefähr 30 km/h.
Genau.
Das heißt, dieses Handy hier im Raum hat
schon 30 km/h aber für Peter Parker reicht das nicht.
Das müssen wir hoch skalieren.
Wenn der durch so eine Häuserschlucht fliegt,
dann ist er schneller.
Peter Parker schwingt neben den Autos her,
das bedeutet die Geschwindigkeit von ihm ist gut doppelt so groß.
Das nehmen wir jetzt an? Genau, das nehmen wir an.
Peter Parker macht auf jeden Fall so 50 bis 60
km/h.
Und die Länge, von Peter Parkers Faden wenn
er durch Häuserschluchten schwingt, ist auf
jeden Fall auch mindestens doppelt so groß. Und damit können wir jetzt rechnen.
Wir kriegen die Kraft, die auf den Faden wirkt,
raus als die Masse von Peter Parker.
Das sind 76 kg, das sagt das Internet, mal
die Beschleunigung – die doppelte Beschleunigung
die auf Peter Parker mit einem doppelt so
langen Faden und doppelter Geschwindigkeit wirken würde.
Okay das heißt, wir haben nicht mehr die
12, 5 m/s² sondern jetzt 25.
Genau.
Zusammen mit der Masse, 76 kg, multipliziert
mit diesen 25 m/s², ergibt sich eine Kraft von 1900 Newton.
Diese wirkt auf den Faden. So, das haben wir jetzt erstmal so ausgerechnet.
Jetzt ist die Frage: Hält dieser Faden?
Weil der richtige Spinnenfaden ist ja viel
dünner als das was Peter Parker schießt.
Genau.
Spinnenfäden sind natürlich viel viel dünner
und würden auf jeden Fall schon reißen,
wenn Peter Parker einfach nur da dran hängt.
Es kommt jetzt noch drauf an, wie dick der
Faden ist und das beschreibt die Fadenspannung.
Diese beschreibt, welche Kraft auf welche
Querschnittsfläche wirkt.
Dazu setzen wir diese 1900 Newton an und bei
der Querschnittsfläche nehmen wir an, dass das ein Kreis ist.
Das ist π * r², kennt man aus der Schule.
Wir nehmen einfach mal an: Der Durchmesser
des Fadens sind 0,5 cm.
Und wenn wir das ausrechnen kommt raus, das
die Fadenspannung 9,7 * 10⁷ N/m² ist.
Vergleichen wir das mit einem Spinnfaden:
Der ist viel stabiler.
Ein Spinnfaden hält ungefähr die tausendfache
Belastung aus.
Also da sind wir auf jeden Fall safe.
Das heißt, selbst wenn wir jetzt hier ein
bisschen Verallgemeinert haben, haben wir
noch einen Faktor Tausend innerhalb dessen
wir uns bewegen könnten.
Das heißt, wir können aus dieser Berechnung
mit Sicherheit sagen: Peter Parker würde
problemlos an seinem Faden durch die Häuserschluchten schwingen können.
Fassen wir zusammen!
Spider-Man könnte, mit ordentlich Haaren
an Händen und Füßen, wirklich Wände hoch
klettern, sein Spinnfaden würde Fahrstuhlkabinen
aufhalten und auf jede Fall nicht reißen,
wenn er durch eine Häuserschlucht fliegt. Auf jeden Fall!
Henry, vielen vielen Dank fürs durchrechnen
und erklären… immer wieder gern!
Wir waren auf jeden Fall nicht zum letzten
Mal hier, deswegen schreibt Ihr uns doch bitte
neue Superhelden, die wir für Euch durchrechnen
können, in die Kommentare.
Ansonsten erstmal bis nächsten Mittwoch! Bis dann, ciao!